last topic for today's pftot something
that continues to generate news and look
i i didn't start it colin kaepernick
didn't start it the media didn't start
it the fans didn't start it everybody
was minding their own business last week
when the news came out that colin
kaepernick would have a workout in
atlanta for all teams and chris
i go back to that moment when i saw the
first report from adam schefter i just
assumed kaepernick set it up yeah and i
had somebody from the league reach out
to me and say we actually set this up
it's like
okay thank you
why
like
it still makes no sense to me a week
later why the nfl as its 100th season
begins to progress toward the playoffs
why in the world are you throwing for
lack of a better phrase this turd into
the punch bowl why are you doing this
this is a topic that you don't want to
deal with this is something that you
don't want to mess with your teams
haven't offered this guy a workout in 32
months what are you trying to prove here
and everything that unfolded after that
just confirmed over and over and over
again what a bad idea it was for the
league to say we're going to set up a
workout for you because they should have
known given the history between the
parties there's going to be suspicion
there's going to be mistrust you can
extend an olive branch and colin
kaepernick's people are going to be
braced that they're going to get whacked
over the head with the olive brand yeah
and that that poisoned this from the
outset they never should have done it
you need a better understanding of the
circumstances and just let the sleeping
dogs lie that's what they should have
done well it i mean i think there's so
many things at play here it's certainly
not a good look for colin kaepernick or
the nfl i mean that's the first thing i
would say second off i mean do we know
how long this was being planned
beforehand
that's where we're not like quite sure
yet either and i don't care i don't care
here's the thing sometimes as you make
plans to do something at some point
along the way
you
have that moment of clarity where you
say you know this probably isn't a good
idea and that's where you need to be
able and this is a challenge when you
have expended time and effort and
thought to a certain project yep
your ego gets caught up in it we can't
stop now we've spent time working on
this we can't stop now we've already
decided to do it well you can stop any
time you want so i don't care if it was
six weeks or six months it was a bad
idea and i don't care what the objective
was yeah if you want to get the guy back
in the league you start picking up the
phone and calling people and saying do
me a favor here give this guy a workout
do me a favor sign this guy man look at
your depth chart at quarterback you
could use this guy sign this guy you
will get x from us you want to host a
draft you'll host a draft you want to
host a super bowl you'll host a super
bowl now that's an extreme carrot to
dangle but there are at any given time
a broad array of issues that teams are
working on the league about different
concerns different things and there's
plenty of basis for a horse trade yeah
that's what you do that's what i did
with michael sam yeah so i i just
i don't know
that the league truly wanted to get him
back in the league wanted to create the
impression they're trying to get her
back in yeah and
whatever the league's intent
kaepernick's people were suspicious from
the get-go and they had to know that
they were going to be suspicious see if
you're truly interested in getting a guy
a job
you sit down you know you don't they
should have negotiated a waiver that
made sense for both sides that's the
first thing that's a different issue
that's the difference i'm talking about
i'm trying to agree on the parameters of
the workout every point here's a point
but chris
when you have uh
something that you
you tell colin kaepernick about on a
tuesday and you're gonna do it on a
saturday four days isn't enough time to
work out all the stuff that needs to be
worked out to do it that's part of what
you have to take into account you have
to look at how are we going to present
this to him like
you know maybe you offer to come to him
hey we'd like to meet with you and you
know oh this is i wonder what this is
all about we want to sit down we want to
talk to you it's just the presentation
of the first concept is critical yeah
your flexibility or lack thereof when
requests are made or questions are asked
i mean you're going to be leery if
you're calling cabinet you've litigated
against these people you've taken
between one and 10 million dollars out
of their coffers they're not happy with
you you think they were trying to pull a
fast one on them by signing that waiver
that had kind of the cryptic language
where
you know they could basically say that
you know he's
he's free and clear after this moment
i'll say this yeah i'll say neither side
was interested in getting colin
kaepernick on a team right both sides
had other agendas at play you have seen
the agenda was not let's get colin
kaepernick on a team because here's what
happens and you mentioned the waiver
they send the waiver on a wednesday i
have the waiver i studied the waiver
yesterday i couldn't
let a client of mine sign that waiver in
light of the history between the two
sides i think that would be malpractice
to do it because it can be interpreted
in a way if you're going to be
aggressive right later right if the crap
hits the fan later it can be interpreted
in a way that you've signed away your
right to a second collusion lawsuit to a
lawsuit alleging that you were
retaliated against because you filed the
first lawsuit and that can be a very
very viable claim right because it's
very easy to find the motivation yeah
the motivation is we don't like this guy
right because he sued us and we had to
pay him money and we don't want him to
slice again right to pay him again and
hey look we've we've found this way and
so so it's but here's what should have
happened and here's where i think colin
kaepernick's camp
got it wrong
the moment you get that thing and read
it that's the moment you call your
contact at the league office and say
look this this release just sent me it's
got some language in here that may be a
little too broad and we all know what
potentially could happen we don't want
to foreclose anything here there could
be a decision made to file a second
grievance
we should make sure that he preserves
that surely you're not trying to take
his way his right to do it and the
league was oh no we're not trying to
take away his right to do it but you
know if we can somehow luck into the
opportunity to make the argument later
that he's signed away those rights we'll
take it right that and so there should
have been a negotiation then and there
they should have
gone back and forth with alternate
language to make it clear that he's not
given up those rights what happened
instead
no significant action was taken on the
waiver until the day before the thing
when
kaepernick's people went and got a
different release a georgia tech
football release which was very short
and said this is what he'll sign well
that sets up the fight see i think
that neither side was serious about this
being a real opportunity to get back
into the nfl so it was about playing
chess
and it was about posturing and
positioning so at the end of the day we
win the pr battle and if there's another
legal battle we win that too yeah that's
what i think was going on from both
sides yeah the league side and colin
kaepernick yeah i mean i i definitely
agree with you with the league side uh i
do and you know i just wish colin you
know i guess i in my heart of hearts
yeah i you know this was at least again
i don't know if it was totally realistic
but a chance for colin kaepernick i
think
to put the pressure on the nfl even more
here
that's where i think it's all i think he
was ill-advised through this
don't sign the waiver
but still have the work out there in
atlanta at the facility don't make it an
hour away that's the only thing i would
argue
because
here's the thing about an hour away yeah
and look
and for every
position one side takes the other side
has a response does it change things for
you if i tell you that one hour away
from that falcons facility also was on
the way to the airport that you're going
to be passing by there on the way to the
airport anyway does that change your one
hour away criticism yeah i mean it does
a little bit i won't deny that there's
no doubt about it but i just know from
the people i talked that were there too
we're like you know we're there at 3 15
and we're being told that the workout's
gonna start at four o'clock and we're
not going to get there in time either
right so right that's what this hit the
fan at 2 30. then the question becomes
but i don't think it filtered out to the
scouts and everything who were there on
the field kind of waiting around until
then it gets back to my point that both
sides were to block i agree i agree i
just again because i'm rooting for colin
kaepernick and i again he's obviously
one of the 64 best quarterbacks in the
in the world right now i mean he
obviously should be on a team from
playing standpoint but it just opens you
know again the door of criticism from
the people that are haters against them
from the people who say he doesn't
really want to play
uh and then the teams that might have
even been dangling with the opportunity
of like oh maybe we'll sign him now it
just opens it like oh we can't sign him
this will just be a fiasco it'll be
immediate
but it's the same thing it always was
going to be because here's the problem
this is like when you have tim tebow on
your roster as a backup yes there's
going to be that group of people who
constantly says he should be playing he
should be playing anytime the starter
throws an incomplete pass he should be
playing remember what they did in denver
they jumped him over kyle orton he
should be playing he should be playing
now over over brady quinn kyle orton was
a starter quinn was a backup tebow was
number three but we're pushing tebow to
the top of the stack ball made himself
available as a rookie every day to the
media which everybody like i know rub
people but the same thing the same thing
will happen you're right colin
kaepernick if he's the second string or
third string quarterback on another team
then the next step is going to be we
want to see him on the field we want to
see what he can do i just think i just
like i said i just wish he would have
gone and stayed there
did the workout but what but how do you
but the problem is they got to resolve
the waiver see this the the screw the
waiver he worked out without a waiver
anyways but that's all i'm just going to
let him work out at the falcons facility
yeah you're right that's the issue and
the other thing too was the video crew
he wanted he wanted to have full
transparency he wanted to have a video
crew next to the falcons video crew so
whatever is generated matches yeah right
and and you can roll your eyes and you
can fall and you can scoff but that
reflects a failure to understand the
poisonous nature of the relationship and
i have dealt with relationships like
that when i was practicing law and it
gets to a point where
the concerns that the parties who have
been fighting forever have seem
unreasonable to those of us on the
outside why was it so hastily planned
why didn't they fall
why didn't they all get together like
three weeks ago and go through here's
what we want for the workout let's make
this work so that's where it just seems
yeah that's right no it seems here's
what you do if you really want to do
this you get on the phone and you say
colin we'd like to come meet with you
yeah we'd like to take you out to dinner
we'll get a private room at a restaurant
near you
and and uh we want and and have your
agent show up and we're going to have
that we got something we want to talk to
you about yep and it's good okay
um
that's how that's at a minimum what you
just call them up say hey we're doing
this on saturday you got two hours to
let us know whether or not you want to
do it what the hell is that right well
can we do it on a tuesday no can we do
it next saturday no it's got to be this
saturday yeah well why why i know i mean
it and beca and again you have to take
into account the relationship is already
fractured beyond repair that's the issue
you can't unring that bell and the nfl
tried hastily and and again
is this about getting it back in the
league is this about pr is this about
coming out of it with a piece of paper
that you can wave around at some point
later saying aha he signed the document
that allows us to defeat his legal
claims if you're colin kaepernick and
you're his agent lawyer you have to be
worried about all that stuff yeah it's
not unreasonable and then it became
gamesmanship and that's where both sides
are to blame yes it wasn't about the
best possible opportunity for him to get
back in on either side it was about
putting yourself in the best possible
light
as this thing continues to go forward
wherever it may go but here's the bottom
line by doing this folks
the nfl has invited that second lawsuit
the nfl has taken
a a
noxious
toxic stew that had been on the back
burner with the fire just at that little
flicker where it's barely on right and
they cranked it they pulled to the front
they cranked it all the way up yeah and
that was stupid it was they should have
just not done anything i agree
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports